Alright everybody,
I'm doing something a little different
with the direct message this week.
I'm actually in the suburbs of DC at the
moment.
You can probably hear the Cicadas in the
background.
Uh,
I wanted to do a direct message about
the RNC and everything that's going on
in Cleveland right now.
But then last night you all have heard
this already.
Milo Yiannopoulos was officially banned
for all time for the rest of human
existence.
He was banned on twitter.
You know,
he had lost his blue verification check
a back A.
Obviously Milo and I,
we become sort of comrades were friends.
Uh,
we don't agree on everything.
I've brought him on the show twice and
we've done a couple of other things
where we've had a healthy exchange of
ideas.
We've gone to ucla together where we
were protesting for exercising our right
to free speech.
I've gone out of my way to show some of
the differences that I have with Milo,
for example.
I always make the distinction between
the doctrine of Islam and the various
people that are of Muslim faith who
practice their faith completely
differently.
Some totally nominally and some that are
violent jihadists.
All of the different things that are in
there right now.
Milo was banned from twitter and there
is a free speech issue here and as you
guys know,
I'm all about free speech and the free
exchange of ideas.
So first off,
this is not a first amendment issue.
The First Amendment of the United States
means the government can come through
your for,
for your free speech.
I've said many times before at the
moment in 2016 in America,
I'm not that afraid that the
government's coming from my free speech.
I think we're taking it from ourselves
and I think this is a good example of
it.
You know,
twitter and facebook and snapchat and
the rest of these things,
they become almost too powerful in their
ability to control speech because these
are now the roadways,
right?
These are the super highways for us to
communicate with each other beyond our
ability to pick up the phone and call a
friend and talk to people on the street
and scream from town square.
Our ability to communicate with
literally thousands and thousands and in
Myeloma case hundreds of thousands if
not millions of people on these
platforms.
It's hugely powerful and there is
something that's happening right now
where it's not necessary about the
government,
but it's about companies now.
Look,
they have,
they're a private company.
They're publicly traded reit,
but they,
they are allowed to instill their own
terms of service,
which they did.
And if they say he violated them,
then yes,
they can ban him.
So I'm not saying twitter can't do what
they did.
I'm not saying the government is
involved in this in any way.
I'm just talking about the principles of
the free exchange of ideas and free
speech.
These things are under threat right now.
Look,
obviously,
look,
forget the nitty gritty details of what
happened in the last day or so.
I'm not even fully aware of what
happened and there's a lot of tweets.
I can't follow everybody's tweets every
second to see exactly what happened.
Um,
but the point is that Milo is a
provocateur.
He intentionally shit posts and gets
people riled up and look,
some people respond to that.
And some people will respond to us
something a little more nuanced,
right,
like might do and get into an idea a
little bit differently.
But the point is,
you know,
on twitter there are all kinds of Nazis.
Look,
look at the responses that Ben Shapiro
Milo,
who has fought with Ben Shapiro all the
time and I was trying to moderate a
debate with them.
I hope it's still gonna happen.
Ben Shapiro,
who was an orthodox Jew post anything on
twitter,
he gets a zillion Nazis photoshopping
his head in ovens and horrific picked,
put picturing him in Auschwitz.
All kinds of horrible stuff.
Muslim people get all kinds of horrible
imagery shown to them.
Gay People,
people young.
I get fag and Jus bag and rob about all
the time.
My book,
this is,
they're exercising their free speech if
these people are not calling directly
for violence or acted on violence.
As far as I know,
Milo has never called to harm anybody.
He's never directly called for violence
in any way.
He's a provocateur,
sharing his thoughts.
Uh,
and we have to understand the difference
between words and actions,
right?
Like just somebody sitting in their
basement sharing a Nazi meme and Milo
saying this or that.
Even if it's directed at a person
saying,
well,
I don't like what you're doing to the
girl,
the girl in ghostbusters,
or I didn't like the movie or whatever
it is,
and then he can't control whether his
people say mean things to her,
but that's what the mute button for and
that's what the block buttons for the
point is.
We have to figure out how to have a
healthy exchange of ideas and realize
that not everything that that happens.
I met online world is transferred
directly into the real world.
If real people started using.
If people start,
if a Nazi party appeared and said,
started saying we're going to kill all
the Jews were going to kill all Muslims,
all of this stuff.
Then you have a problem,
a direct call for violence,
but right now that's not where we're at.
And there's an issue here.
So there's a couple issues here,
but to me the primary issue is the power
that these social media companies have
and we can't pretend that they don't
have a political agenda,
right?
These are all pretty left organization,
so of course they're really not going to
like a guy like my look because it's
easy always to attach style,
attack,
stodgy old conservatives and
Republicans.
Milo represents something different.
He's young and cool and gay and British
and blonde and has this huge groundswell
of support.
By the way,
it's his support is from conservatives
and liberals and all sorts of other
things.
I know that because when I went to Ucla
with him,
I had liberals in the audience,
kids college,
kids from Ucla saying that they don't
agree with anything he says,
but they were there to defend his right
to free speech.
So that strikes me a little bit of a
what Obiwan said to Darth Vader,
if you strike me down,
I'll become more powerful than you can
possibly imagine by striking him down
here and banning him from twitter.
They're probably making this movement
that much stronger.
Anyway,
it's.
It's complex and there's a lot of things
here.
I would love to talk to someone from
facebook about this because they band a
couple of people just in the last week
they banned my friend Feisal and my
friend Melissa,
both who'd been on the show,
there'll be reinstated sense.
I would love to talk to Jack from
twitter.
I'd love to talk to any of these tech
people.
So they're welcome to come on the show.
Uh,
I'm not trying to inflame anything any
further.
I,
I genuinely want to have this
conversation.
Uh,
and by the way right now you can go on
twitter and you can check Ayatollah
Khomeini,
his twitter account.
He regularly calls for another
Holocaust.
You can see what's going on with the
president of Turkey,
who right now in the midst of literally
just just assembling democracy there and
arresting protestors and sacking judges
and not letting people leave the country
because they have no problem with him
being on there.
So there's just,
there's an inconsistency in the way they
apply these rules.
It's just a lot of stuff here.
But let's try to have a mature
discussion about it.
And my guest this week,
uh,
so as I said,
we normally do this from the studio in
Los Angeles.
I'm in DC right now.
My guest this week is Michael Ian,
black comedian,
actor,
writer,
great guy.
He is a big in fighting you controls and
we have a really interesting discussion
about fighting trolls and twitter Nazis.
We talk about Milo now.
We shot this last week,
so everything that you're going to see a
is not about what happened,
uh,
yesterday and today we shot it last
week,
but it's a great discussion about these
very issues.
So the timing is perfect,
uh,
and I appreciate it and I'll be back in
studio soon enough.
And as always,
thank you guys for your support.
Here we go.
My guest this week is a comedian and
author,
an actor and a twitter Nazi hunter.
Michael Ian Black.
Welcome to the show.
Thank you.
Which one of those would you say you
mostly are?
Is it twitter,
Nazi hunter,
or comedian?
Probably twitter.
Nazi hunter,
yeah.
Uh,
yeah,
because I'm not particularly funny these
days on twitter.
I'm just annoying you are fighting the
Nazis constantly on twitter.
And my policy with the Nazis is,
congratulations,
you guys came up with a meme and you're
alone in your basement,
but you liked engaging these people or I
don't know if you'd like it,
I don't want to put words in it,
but you do engage with these people.
I think it's,
uh,
I think it's valuable and important to
engage these people.
Yeah.
Because I think it's worth to the larger
public knowing that they're out there
knowing that there is this a sub
subculture.
I don't even know how large it is.
I'm assuming it's very small.
It's like sub so,
but they are very vocal and uh,
my sense is there are
uh,
more sympathizers than a actual
participants and so I feel sort of duty
bound to hold to hold them up as idiots
so that,
those who may be inclined to sympathize
though.
Oh wait,
they're idiots.
Yeah,
they're always anonymous too.
Are you ever finding a Nazi that's like,
hi,
I'm a Nazi,
you know,
this is my real picture
new.
It's always,
uh,
it's always either some pre pubescent
Japanese anime Avatar or some repurposed
like Hitler Youth Avatar.
Right.
What do you make of the Japanese
anime thing with related to that,
because I don't think there's any
connections between Japanese and there.
No,
not between a Japanese anime and Hitler,
but there's absolutely some kind of
connection between,
uh,
those who would move towards that
ideology and fetishizing pre pubescent
Japanese girls.
There's actually a connection there and
I'll leave it to brighter minds than
mine to try to tie those two things
together.
But that absolutely exists.
You're just exposing them and now it's
for the social scientists that's trying
to figure out that you.
Are you ever afraid that sometimes that
by fighting with them that it's almost
like elevating their relevance because
that's a little bit of not fighting with
them,
but by exposing them and arguing,
there's absolutely a case to be made for
that.
And uh,
but I think it's,
I think it's more important from my
point of view to show that they're there
to just say,
look,
this is,
this is who we're living among.
And in the context of the current
political climate,
I think it's important to let people
know that these people exist and that,
uh
hmm.
Given the right circumstances,
more of them could pop up.
Yeah.
Now I take it you're not against.
You wouldn't be for banning them.
Right?
Like you're just,
you're exposing them,
but you wish you would let them do their
job.
What you do.
That's,
that's why we have a first amendment.
Yeah.
Alright,
good.
Um,
so,
and I don't report them.
I don't do any of that shit.
Yeah,
I just,
I,
I just showed them.
Yeah.
So let's back up to the first thing you
said,
which is I used to be flooding.
Is that what you said?
I used to be funny,
right?
I am not.
Yeah,
just annoying.
Yeah.
So I feel that since I've been doing
this,
I mean I did stand up and 12,
12 years in New York and a couple years
out here I used to be funny.
I was,
I mean I can get you some letters to
show you later.
I was funny at one time,
but now I'm talking about all these
serious stuff all the time and I like to
try to pepper some comedy in there when
I can.
But there's,
the world just feels particularly crazy
right now,
doesn't it?
Which should be ideal for comedy,
right?
But I'm not,
I'm not good at making light of things
that I find deadly serious and I'm just
not good at it.
I mean there's,
there's great political comedians out
there and I'm not one of them.
Yeah.
I can talk about my own life,
I think in a funny way,
but I can't.
I mean there's,
there's,
there's people better able to talk about
trump and be hilarious than me.
So we'll get to trump in a second.
So,
um,
you,
I always think of you more so as or
until the last year or so.
I always thought it'd be more as like
social commentary,
all the bad stuff,
all that stuff.
And a lot of the movies you've been in
seward,
more like personal social commentary.
Did you ever think you were going to be
more in the political sphere?
Because that's sort of where I put you
now.
Well,
I mean,
I don't,
not that insert myself in the political
sphere now.
I mean the last thing the world needs is
another jerk off community spouting off
about politics.
I don't,
I don't aspire to be that person,
but if I can set aside being a comedian
and just be a citizen who's interested
in this stuff,
that's sort of how I view myself.
I mean I.
I definitely am not.
I'm not an activist.
I'm not marching.
I take no action.
I do nothing other than I have this
twitter platform and that's,
that's how I express myself politically.
You do tweet while flying first class
because that's the first time we had any
face to face interaction.
I was going to go away in the back and
you sort of dismissively wave as it was
very.
It was embarrassing for both of us as a
first class.
I've only flown first class once and it
was on a little plane from Detroit to
New York,
so it was like eight people and I was
first class was just that.
I was in the first seat.
It wasn't anything special,
but as a first class,
are you.
Do you feel that we shouldn't be allowed
to look at you?
I always feel like when I'm walking
through I shouldn't be allowed to learn
misunderstanding part.
Maybe the main Julia first class which
were seated first.
Yeah,
so that.
So you,
the people walking back are forced to
look at us already ensconced in our
blanket already ordering our beverage of
choice.
Maybe you're already asleep.
Maybe getting massaged from the chair.
Like there's all kinds of things that
it's important for the business model of
the airlines and for my own self esteem,
they walking back to steroids that I
have that you do not.
That's interesting because I always
thought they should be one way glass so
that you could lock it us,
but that we have no desire to see you.
Yeah.
You don't exist for me.
Very much exist for you.
Wow.
You're thinking about those fuckers in
first class while you're crammed in.
Starting little seat stewing for the
duration of your flight on that jet blue
flight though.
Jet Blue,
let's you get your own soda.
You know you can go to like a thing and
I was almost going to peek around the
curtain and just like,
oh,
they would know.
Or did you out?
Yeah,
and I know you would've called people
and it would,
it would've been,
they would've landed us in Salt Lake
City or something.
It would've been,
it would've been a disaster.
I'm glad you didn't do that.
I'm glad you had the foresight to know
better than to do that.
Can Get.
You would have been escorted out
immediately.
Well,
speaking of social,
full pause.
Let's move over to trump because you
have written a children's book about
trump.
Yes.
So you must love trump.
I assume if you wrote a children's,
everyone loved children's books and um,
here's my problem.
Despise trump wrote a book about trump,
uh,
a sort of
a
kind of a children's book,
a parody of a children's book,
but it was a children's book at the same
time.
Um,
so I am exploiting the trump brand as
much as an actual trump and making money
off the trump brand.
So I don't know.
So you're using it right?
You're using a trumpy and tactics on
trump.
That's right,
yeah.
Where did the idea to make it a
children's book come from?
Uh,
I was at a bookstore and I saw a book
about Hillary Clinton as sort of a
children's book,
a rags to riches story about Hillary
Clinton,
and an inspirational tale started,
I think at young girls,
and it made me chuckle a bit to think
about what that would be like if you
were to write about trump because he's
not an inspirational figure in any way,
shape or form.
He's just a toad.
And so,
uh,
I,
I just thought level,
let me try to do that.
So He's a toad.
Is that why they're used?
You know,
that toad thing?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Where did that come from?
I Know Kiki or.
Yeah.
I don't know where there's a toad with
trump hair,
but there's a lot of toads.
Yeah.
On that,
on that part of the Internet,
they,
what's with the Pto?
I don't know.
We don't know.
We have no idea.
I don't know.
It took me long enough to figure out
what the three parentheses meant.
Wait,
wait.
So the two?
No,
it's three Jewish three.
Yeah,
it's,
it's.
Yeah.
I see.
Oh,
because they came.
There were some list or something that
was exposed where they tried to expose
people to something like that came
later.
The,
the uh,
the three parentheses is meant to
indicate an echo,
right?
Uh,
and it's like the Jewish Echo.
I'm not sure quite what that means,
but that's what the three parentheses
are meant to indicate.
Is that just that,
like a nagging mother?
I don't think so.
I think it's something worse.
Oh,
I think it's far worse than that.
I'm a.
and then there was an app that just
identified Jews for you.
Right?
I don't know.
It's insane.
Yeah.
So what do you make of just the general
climate right now?
Because to me,
I've been off until this show and we did
one more.
We'd launched relaunched last week and
uh,
for the three weeks that I took off,
so to speak,
you can see the world not the world was.
I was paying attention.
I just didn't have a show to talk about
it.
And it seems like the world went even
more crazy.
Don't you think the last month seems
like particularly nuts,
you know,
sort of starting probably with the pulse
shooting and then,
I mean,
I wouldn't say I'm,
I'm,
I'm past the point of being surprised
that anything is happening.
Yeah,
it all feels of a piece to me and I feel
like I can kind of grasp the outlines of
what that piece is,
which is the larger story is sort of
what,
what is,
what is fueling all of this.
Um,
and I think there's an,
I look,
I'm,
I'm not particularly savvy about this.
I'm just regurgitating what I've read,
but it really does feel like we're at a
moment where the foundations of
capitalism are,
are crumpling and nobody knows what to
do.
So is that the scary part that nobody
knows what to because I,
I agree.
It feels like something that there's a
real shift happening right now and it's
almost like we have no leaders when,
where even if you love trump and if you
have loved Clinton and Obama is on the
way out,
but even if you love him,
that we don't have leaders who talk to
us in an honest way and that that's part
of the problem.
Like we're all walking around like,
could somebody,
like,
I feel like everyone's looking around.
Somebody help here.
Is there anyone we could look to for.
First of all,
I don't think trump understands the
problem better than the relative,
the average citizen.
Uh,
he knows how to exploit it,
but he'd,
I don't think he understands it,
but I agree with you that there is not,
knows,
sort of global leader has stepped
forward in a articulate non
condescending way to say this is what
we're going through.
Um,
and here's where I think we need to
move.
It would be great if somebody would do
that.
I'd love for Hillary Clinton to spend an
hour just talking into the camera and
saying,
this is where I think we are.
This is why I think we're here.
This is where I think we need to go in a
very mature,
not alarmist way.
Are you a hillary supporter?
I mean,
I think I have the enthusiasm for
Hillary that a lot of people have,
which is.
Yeah,
I could just picture the gift right
there.
I said,
are you a hillary supporter the other
way you got?
Because that's what everyone does.
No one's like,
there's very,
very.
I know there's a couple,
but everyone supporting hillary,
my friends that had been democrats their
whole life and family members.
Are you supporting hillary?
Well,
but there's good reason for that.
It was easy to gin up that enthusiasm
for Obama because as he himself said,
he was a blank slate.
Hillary has a 20 5:30
year record and it's very easy to cherry
pick what you like and Cherry pick what
you don't like and say she's a villain.
Say she's a hero.
She's a flawed human being as we all
are,
and we know what our flaws are.
So it's like,
you know,
it's,
it's like getting back together with an
old girlfriend or something.
And you're like,
no,
I still love her.
Right.
You know,
I know,
I know it's going to be a pain in the
ass.
God Damn it.
I still love her.
Uh,
that's Kinda what it's like.
So is that a little.
That's kind of dangerous thought though,
because Obama came in with the blank
slate and whether you like him or not,
uh,
the idea that we'd only be okay with
blank slate.
That's what sets the appeal of trump
right now.
Yeah.
Um,
even though his sleep actually is full
of stuff again,
whether you like it or not.
Well it's full of political stuff.
Yeah.
So he,
you know,
one hand races,
what the other hand wrote,
he can be whatever you want him to be as
long as he's a racist because that's
ultimately what people want from him.
So what do you make of the people?
And I get this part,
here's my part of trump that I do
actually get,
forget all the policies for a second,
but I do get the part about,
forget the policies because they were.
Because they're all over the place.
Right.
And I've even had,
I've had ardent trump supporters sit
here like Milo Yiannopoulos,
sit here and basically tell me it's not
about the policies,
it's about this one thing that I'm going
to tell you and I at least get this
part,
which is that this is a cultural
election this time,
it has almost nothing to do with policy.
But the one thing that he's getting with
people,
and I've seen this when I've been to
colleges when liberals are coming up to
me and saying this,
that he's cracking this political
correctness thing.
Now.
The irony of that is I don't think he's
going to be some major free speech
beacon because he talks about suing
reporters all the time,
but at that.
But I do get the level of people are
feeling very repressed right now.
Like they can't say anything and they're
always screamed at in called racist and
all that stuff.
But I don't think you're with me out of
that.
Not at all.
Yeah.
I think
when Milo talks about political
correctness,
that term political correctness has come
to mean,
I think in those circles,
um,
nativism,
racism,
xenophobia,
and what have you,
when you say he's cracked political
correctness,
what he's,
what he's cracked is the,
the agreement that we had been coming to
as a society,
and that agreement was,
um,
diversity is a benefit to the nation,
and tolerance is a benefit to the
nation,
uh,
and having different points of view is a
benefit to the nation that has all
gotten lumped into that agreement has
gotten lumped under political
correctness.
And when he says he's cracked political
correctness,
what he's,
what I think he means is he has,
he's attempting to unravel that
agreement.
And what's left is white nationalism and
nothing else.
No,
because trump's appeal is not policy
based.
He has none.
It's not judgement based.
He seems to have no better judgment than
anybody else in possibly worse.
It's not principle base.
He has none.
It's not character based.
He has very little to none.
All he has is on day one starting with
Mexicans are rapists and whatever else.
He said that's what he has and he's
built on that from that spent his entire
campaign has been a divisiveness and
hatred geared towards angry white males.
Yeah.
Well,
I love,
I love hearing your answer on that
because obviously I've,
I love,
I like Milo and I've given him a
platform and you know,
we work together and stuff.
But the whole point of my show is that I
want to hear that and I want to hear
what you're saying.
Well,
and when I've watched your show,
I've,
I've watched him on it
and you know,
I think he's a disgrace.
I think he's an utter disgrace.
I have a feeling you're going to hear
from him on twitter.
I very well might,
but he's not verified.
So,
uh,
I know,
so at least it starts there and it feels
very calculated and it feels very
machiavellian to me and it feels very
put on and it and it,
uh,
and he is allowing himself to be used,
I think,
as a,
a tool by a,
the intolerant.
Right.
And the fact that he's gay,
for example,
is,
makes it all the more appalling to me,
um,
because he's giving them more license to
say,
well,
we like this guy,
you know,
we like this crazy Brit,
this crazy flaming red or whatever.
Um,
and that is,
I think it unconscionable use of moral
licensing and that he's allowing himself
to be used in that way and,
and promoting himself in that way.
Moral licensing.
I like that.
You just come up with that right there.
That that's something somebody said that
before I learned it from Malcolm
Gladwell.
Oh,
okay.
There you go.
So a moralizing.
So I guess part of this is that our
system is just so broke that anyone that
had a moral license or a moral compass,
would you ever want to run for
president?
I mean,
could you imagine as a,
as a,
as a smart person ever wanting to put
yourself in politics at all?
No.
Yeah.
Is that the bigger problem here that
we're just getting,
we're just getting what we've created,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
if you,
if you have any,
if you've,
if you've lived any kind of life,
hemingway,
for example,
whoever those guys could not run for
office or anybody who's lived a life
that has any
human experience,
right?
So meaning you might have cheated on
your wife,
you might,
if you might need some coke.
Sure,
yeah.
He might've done any number of things
that make us human,
make us flawed human beings.
You know,
that stuff's going to come up.
you're going to be vilified.
You know.
So if you're thinking about running for
office,
somebody like Ted Cruz for example,
who's been thinking about being
president his entire fucking life,
he's lived his life in such a way to
make his resume the resume of a future
president or at very least a senator.
You're not exaggerating by the way.
There's no video of him at like 16.
So I'm gonna.
I'm gonna be president.
Yeah.
Um,
and so you live your life in a way that
is calculatedly
unrelatable to the rest of the nation.
You know,
someone like Bill Clinton,
who I think probably was running for
president his whole life too,
at least he,
he wears his humanity on his sleeve.
He's like,
I'm,
you know,
I'm just a big goober.
Yeah,
and that's part of his appeal,
but I can't imagine subjecting myself to
the kind of public scrutiny that is
required,
knowing that there's people whose job is
to dig up shit on you,
just about your life.
It has nothing to do with your ability
to make good policy decisions.
Yeah.
What does it tell you that when a show.
What was the show with Kevin Spacey?
It's been blank,
but how's the cards?
I watch house of cards and I think,
wow,
there's a lot more reality in that then
anything that I'm watching on CNN,
meanwhile,
all the CNN people are pretending to be
themselves.
I hate that.
By the way.
Do you wait?
Do you like that bugs me.
Drives me fucking crazy.
I wha.
What movie was I watching just these
past couple days ago I was watching one
of the unjust,
some superhero movie and it's like jake
tapper shows every since it was dot who
I like.
I think it was Jacob.
Like what?
What movie was it?
Superhero movies.
Oh,
Batman.
Superman.
I don't know if it was jake actually.
Oh,
it was Anderson Cooper in that when I
was like,
you guys are all pretending to be
yourselves.
Why can't we have alternate universes
where there are also,
we can have.
Kryptonite will also have alternate news
casters.
Don't even hit journalist,
but journalists don't show up in Batman.
Right.
But doesn't mad show it.
It's like they all want to be stars.
So when I say this,
it's probably with some do irony to
people that are public people and share
our opinions,
but it's like they all want to be in.
Right?
They go to the White House
correspondence dinner.
They all want to have dinner with these
people and go to the parties and all
that.
That's to me,
one of the biggest problems we have in
the whole country.
Well,
the,
the political starfucking I guess I
don't really have a problem with it.
I think
it doesn't,
it doesn't upset me maybe the way that
it upsets you because I do feel like,
like in any profession,
most people in any given profession are
trying to do a good job.
Um,
so like when I see Anderson Cooper
reporting on something,
I feel like most of the time he's done
pretty good job,
you know,
I think he's pretty good.
Uh,
Chuck Todd who I think can be a little
supercilious,
but I think he's trying to do a good job
and I think he's doing.
I think he,
I think he approaches things the way he
approaches them for very specific
reason.
It's thought it's thought it's thought
out jake tapper the same way and you
know,
these guys will land punches that kind
of meshing of
politicos and,
and journalists.
It doesn't really upset me because it
seems like,
well,
if you're a journalist you want to have
relationships with these people to get
information.
Yeah.
I guess for me the bigger problem is
that if you ask easy questions and look,
I'm an interviewer,
so if you ask any questions you're going
to get them to come back.
You know what I mean?
So if I had Obama here one time and I
knew this is the one time that maybe
we'll set up the rest of our
relationship,
I don't think I would attack him in a
way that I might the second time,
but even in that that causes a problem
because then they always go at a press
conference are always like,
Oh guy who I know I get easy questions
from,
you know.
Right.
But there's a way to have that
conversation.
Have a tough conversation with him or
with anybody in a way that he doesn't
feel attacked.
You can.
I think most politicians are receptive
to being asked
tough questions in a respectful way.
I thought Jon Stewart was.
He was a master at that.
Jon Stewart would have any conservative
on his show.
He would read their book and he would
grill them about it,
but it was always respectful and I think
as a consequence,
they would come on the show because they
knew they would get a fair hearing for
their ideas.
Then they may end up,
they may have,
they may walk out feeling foolish,
but it's not because of him.
It's because of them.
Yeah.
What do we do,
do you think,
to make people smarter?
Again,
I keep saying that being smart is now
counter culture.
Culture is dumb right now and when I
meet smart people,
I'm like,
thank God.
Culture is gleefully dumb.
That's the problem.
I don't know that as a culture,
we're probably smarter than we've ever
been.
You're right.
There's this attitude that book learning
is somehow anti-american.
Uh,
knowledge is suspect.
Science is political.
It's,
it's very much an up is down,
down is up kind of world.
But I still think that's a,
that's a minority of the,
of,
of the country that really believes
that.
Yeah.
I,
I firmly believe it's a minority,
but it's the minority that we keep
hearing from.
I mean,
that's what I keep saying to the
political side.
It's like we hear from the crazies on
the left and we hear from the crazies on
the right and I would argue that most
people,
I think really 80 percent of us actually
want pretty decent things and pretty
similar things.
I think if you're a,
if you're just a regular conservative,
you don't want a world that's very
different from what the average liberal
really want.
You might have a couple of policies.
So how do we,
how do we get those voices to be heard
again?
Well,
for one thing I think it's important to
to for the larger
a national dialogue to state what you
just stated,
which is true and I would say it's even
larger than 80 percent.
We all essentially want the same things.
We want safe communities,
we want opportunities for our kids.
We wanted the ability to make a little
money and feel like if we,
to use the tritus political expression,
work hard and play by the rules will get
ahead.
That's basically all people want right
on,
on both sides.
So if conservatives can agree with that
statement and Liberals can agree with
that statement,
you go,
fine,
we know where we're going.
It's really just a question of tactics
on how we get there.
That's where we disagree.
But as long as we keep in mind that the
goal is the same,
I think we can work together,
but we become so,
and this is largely a result of,
of uh,
at the entertainment aspect of
journalism,
we become so polarized because that's
what drives eyeballs to television
screens is people yelling at each other
as opposed to people having comity and
being like,
oh yeah,
we agree.
We basically agree,
right?
Yeah.
And that's the irony is people want
that.
I know they want to because they're
messaging me every day saying that what
I'm here is what they want to see the
guy that you're important,
you're doing God's work.
We get it.
Dave.
Listen,
if 100 other people were doing this,
I would gladly find something else to
do.
You know what I mean?
I really would.
And that would show a good sign that
some smarter things have had occurred
here.
Yeah.
That I,
I,
I wrote a book a few years ago with my
friend,
Megan Mckenna.
I wanted to ask you about that.
Yeah.
Uh,
and that was essentially the central
thesis of the book,
which is we all kind of want the same
things.
We differ on the margins may be a bit
about guns for example.
Um,
but even then we don't because
conservatives and liberals both want gun
debts to fall.
Right.
It's just a question of how we get
there.
There's a certain disingenuousness I
think on the part of the right about how
we get there and in fact entirely
disingenuousness,
but just from a,
from a purely philosophical point of
view,
both sides would like to reduce gun
deaths.
Yeah.
So then it's just how do we get there?
So when you wrote that book,
and that's actually when I had you on my
Sirius xm show many lifetimes ago when
you wrote that,
and I think I had megan on maybe the
next week or something.
Um,
what made you think like,
oh,
I should talk to her because she's
obviously she's in it.
Her Dad's a pretty powerful guy who ran
for president and you know,
she's on the right and I do continue.
I mean,
do you consider yourself on the left?
You just.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
what made you think that,
like,
this is the apprentice ears.
You got to do that.
A couple more parentheses.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What made you think like,
let me talk to her and let's do this
because that was ahead of its.
Yeah,
that was,
that was the reason it was.
She's somebody who I should have very
little in common with.
Let's go on the road together and write
a book and see if we can sort of bring
these issues to light a little bit.
And we did a,
it was fun and we wrote a good book and
nobody bought it.
Nobody wants to hear more similar than
dissimilar.
Yeah.
That's such a dangerous.
That's the thing I want to unpack with
this more than anything else is like
we've got to get past it and it's,
it's uh,
you know,
I turn on CNN and it's like,
people think they're watching news and
they're not watching news.
They are literally watching Wolf Blitzer
debate between the trump spokesman and a
hillary spokesmen and people think that
that's news.
Meanwhile brexit happens and we don't
even.
We literally,
I watched CNN almost a full day just
trying to see like what are they going
to show us with,
onto the background.
They didn't know the audio on the whole
time,
but like there was nothing.
There was like one 32nd thing every four
hours.
Right.
So it's like our media is just making
this dumb too.
Yes
and no.
I think there's a certain percentage of
the population that will look at the
coverage of brexit and be curious enough
to want to understand more what that
means and there's a much larger
percentage of the population that
understands the headline of what Brexit
is and doesn't need to pursue that any
further.
And then there's a certain amount of the
population who doesn't give a shit,
but I put it,
but it hasn't.
That always been the way I've always
been the case,
that,
that you know,
that I don't,
I don't,
I,
if anything,
I feel like we're more engaged as a
nation than we've ever been on almost
because we can't help but be the.
And I think that that's good and bad.
I think what's going on in the country
right now,
there's,
there's absolutely a pollyanna ish way
of looking at it and saying this is
actually quite good.
What's happening.
That there is a,
I mean,
aside from people just being gone down
in the streets,
which is great.
Um,
so you're saying that the issues that
are being earthed up are good.
The question is yes
or being dredged up.
Yeah.
Aren't necessarily issues.
Um,
and they're being brought to the fore by
two imperfect messengers and that's
fine.
That's fine.
Uh,
so as we're taping this right now,
black lives matters in the throes of.
There's a lot of stuff going on.
I mean,
between the shootings of the black
people that has obviously been going on
for quite some time up,
but these last few in particular and now
the,
the bride or the protests against it and
then the cop shootings and everything
else where,
where do you kind of fall on all of this
stuff?
Because I find it very hard and even
even as I'm prefacing this,
I know that no matter what we say right
now,
a certain amount of people are going to
hate it.
No,
you know what I mean?
Even if they agree with us on 99
percent,
if we say one word the wrong way,
people will start freaking,
but I.
So I haven't talked about it that much
because I find it's very hard to
decipher what's actually happening by
watching little clips of things.
Well,
there's a few things we know that are
happening.
Yeah.
Let's start with the black lives matter
side of it and instantly,
I don't think these are two opposing
sides,
but just,
yeah,
separating them out.
We know that black people are being
killed by police.
We know that.
We've known it for years.
Uh,
we've known it for generations,
we've known him for centuries.
Black people get killed.
Um,
what changed is obviously the ability to
live stream those debts as they're
occurring.
It has changed the dialogue.
It's very hard for white people to now
say or not to,
to,
to live in any kind of denial about
that.
Now,
when you see the evidence presented in
front of you and there's a lot of white
people trying very hard to maintain that
denial,
very hard,
but I think most of us look at that and
go,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
we knew what you were saying for the
last 300 years,
I guess.
That's right.
Yeah.
The blatant denial people are the ones
that drive me nuts because you can say
that we can get to the other part of
this too.
You can say there's some legitimate
issues there,
but it's the people that no matter what
happens,
no matter what evidence they're shown,
they immediately go to that.
It goes to character assassination
immediately.
Yeah.
Right,
right,
right.
If somebody had a weed in the car or
whatever,
well they deserve to get shot.
No,
no,
they didn't.
Right,
so there's that side of it and then the
other side is a,
that violence gets redirected towards
police and I haven't heard anybody
defend that in any way,
shape or form other than a couple of
crazy people on twitter just being
idiots.
The two on the two ideas are not
opposed.
We shouldn't be killing people like
that.
Let's just start with that central
premise.
People are dying unnecessarily.
Yeah.
And there I believe that there is a uh,
incredibly entrenched,
I don't know,
and there's no polite word for it.
Racist Culture in police culture.
I've seen enough evidence and read
enough account and spent enough time
looking at,
added into it to suggest that that is a
problem,
a real problem,
a genuine problem.
Um,
for probably a plethora of historical
and cultural reasons.
So something's broken with policing and
I think always has been,
but now we're just seeing it.
Um,
that needs to change.
Hm.
The idea that the police force,
we've come to think of more and more as
a militarized force as an extension of
the military.
That has to change.
It's weird.
It's weird that.
Sorry to cut you off,
but it's weird that people don't see
that.
That piece of it where when we have
these tanks out there are not taxed,
but these armored vehicles on our
streets,
it happened and that doesn't truly.
Yeah,
and that doesn't feel like if you were
just looking at it,
we're moving specifics.
We armored tanks on our streets,
forget why they're there,
but that in and of itself,
this alarm,
a problem.
You should.
You should have to call the national
guard tank and pick up the phone call.
Gomer pyle haven't bring the tank.
There's no reason the police forces need
them,
but what it does is it inculcates an us
versus them mentality,
both from the police point of view and
from the community's point of view and
the idea of community policing is lost.
The idea of to protect and serve is lost
because it's become a a.
The the these police precincts I think
in many communities have come to feel
like occupying forces as opposed to
extensions of the community.
That's a real problem.
The fact that the fact that police
routinely recruit from the military I
think is a problem.
There's no,
there's,
there's no real linkage between those
two organizations.
The police are paramilitary to a certain
extent,
but the local police force in my mind
should be essentially liaison from,
uh,
the law,
law enforcement to the community.
And it should be a partnership.
It should be a two way street.
Right?
So in army is dealing with enemy
combatants,
but by definite way that police
obviously she's right there,
like definition and army is dealing
with,
with an opposing force.
Yeah.
And when you recruit from the military
to fill out your police ranks,
I have a hard time believing that
they're not going to bring that
mentality to policing and it infects the
entire culture.
And it's been that way now for I think
decades.
So what do you make of [inaudible]?
One of the things that I've struggled
with,
this is what I see the protests and
there in the middle of the street where
they're not supposed to be on highways
and things and you know when they've
been burning cars or whatever it is or
or looting sorts of things.
Look,
those things are not legal.
You're allowed to protest,
but you can't shut down highways and
all.
That's a.
and usually the cop usually not always
of course,
but usually you see the cops basically
trying to keep law and order so it sort
of a self fulfilling prophecy here,
right?
Because you could.
You create something,
you do something illegal even if the
intentions are good.
Let's see.
Your motives are good,
but you shut down a highway which you
can't do.
Now.
The cops have to do something and now
you've created this stalemate here and
now of course everyone's got cameras in
everybody's face and they're just
waiting for the pin drops,
right?
To set the whole thing off.
So how do we,
how do we unfurl some of that?
This is given two different examples
that I think are not quite the same to
me.
There's a big difference between sitting
down in the middle of a highway and
burning a car and looting a store.
Sure.
But both are legal.
Both are illegal.
One is causing a property damage and
destruction.
And is,
is essentially a violent act versus the
nonviolent protest of sitting down in
the middle of a highway.
You could be stopping ambulances that
needed to get in all kinds of other
stuff,
but you could also do those sit downs
in a park.
You can,
you know,
but,
but you don't get the fanfare.
Right.
And,
and protest is about spectacle.
That is,
that is it's point.
Um,
so I may be annoyed at the people
sitting in the middle of the highway,
um,
but I don't have the same reaction to
that as I do to people being
destructive.
Sure.
In their community.
And I think I,
I,
I think sitting down in the highways a
perfectly viable,
a nonviolent demonstration where I think
black lives matter is falling short.
Um,
and I,
I,
I was reading a commenter commentator on
twitter,
Oliver Willis,
who was talking about this all night
[inaudible]
without a directed legislative agenda.
It's so much smoke,
but there's no,
it can't catch fire.
There's no substance there.
Um,
and I think that's true.
I think,
I think at this point,
the black lives matter umbrella because
it's not really sounded organization,
it's whoever wants black lives matter
can claim it wherever you can claim
yourself to be a member of black lives
matter and you are um,
but it needs,
it needs more directed leadership.
It needs to have some stated legislative
and policy goals.
Otherwise all you're doing is you're
raising awareness for something that
people already know exists.
This is the inherent problem with that
though,
that they feel the system has failed
them either,
either true or not.
So they're there.
Their goal is
to
make waves,
not necessarily like they're trying to
change the system in a way that the
system doesn't want to change.
Like that's where this thing's at
loggerheads,
right?
Yeah.
But like if a guy came out and said,
I have this legislation that's going to
do this and this and this,
it's almost like,
well,
the protesters wouldn't,
wouldn't be down with that.
That's possible because again,
it's the blank slate theory.
It's easy to say,
I'm,
I project all my hopes onto x,
x candidate x political movement.
It's much harder to go to then take the
next step to y and Z and saying,
well,
here are some legislative,
uh,
differences we can make and it's not
going to be perfect because it never is.
But we can move.
We can move ourselves forward in fits
and starts.
Yeah,
that's what we need.
Wouldn't it be fun to talk about some of
this stuff with some level of comedy
involved?
But I get ya.
I get ya.
I warned you in an email and I prepare
for me not to be funny.
I'm not going to be funny.
And I said I wanted one applause break.
We don't even have a studio audience.
What I was hoping for.
One,
one,
minor applause.
Break there.
I don't know how to talk about this
stuff with that.
Funny Way,
I mean I just,
I find it interesting,
I mean I'm just,
I'm just some dude who reads the
newspaper and it's just interested in it
and doesn't,
doesn't pretend to know how to make it
funny.
Are there any comics right now that you
really think you're hitting this out of
the
park?
Just sort of the general political
stuff.
Yeah.
You know the,
the people who came from the daily show,
I think our
still doing the best work in that arena.
We need John Back.
Right?
I had some issues with them,
but I think we need him back.
He was the best.
Yeah,
I think he is coming back right?
He's got some HBO.
He's going to do like little snippets on
hbo or something,
but I mean sort of that nightly long
form.
It would be great.
It really wouldn't be.
Yeah.
So let's,
let's shift to movies and comedy and TV
and,
but,
but we can probably circle it back to
some horrific societal stuff and end of
civilization stuff,
but in case society ends,
I want you to at least be able to share
your thoughts on some of the movies
you've made.
Some of the others about Wonky Shit.
All right,
well we'll let you know what,
five minutes of it.
I was going to go for 12 to 15.
We'll do five minutes away and then
we'll finish back with all this stuff.
Um,
so first off I was telling you right
before we sat down,
uh,
that you were in wet hot American
summer,
which I hadn't seen until about a year
ago.
Even though I went to one of those
camps.
I went to Camp Shannon wind up in
Pennsylvania and I thought it was one of
the most absolutely hilarious we've ever
seen.
I watched the series on Netflix,
which now you're just telling me you're
writing for season two,
right?
Which is pretty great.
But you didn't write for.
She just not right for season one,
I did not write the movie.
Yeah.
Is that hard for you and in a movie like
that where there's a,
it's so many of your friends obviously
writing and you didn't get to write but
you have to just act it.
Is that harder than if you're writing
for it and acting on it?
Uh,
no.
I mean
I've been friends with all of those guys
essentially my entire adult life.
So
it says if I wrote it,
yeah,
you know,
we,
we share a sensibility.
So it's just,
it was just fun and it's not like they
were so precious with the words that you
couldn't,
so they let you kind of do your thing.
I would imagine you guys are having a
great time because it's great.
It's really fun.
Yeah.
And now now I'm,
I mean I'm nervous writing for it
because I feel like I have something to
live up to write as a writer,
which I,
I didn't have to showing up on set.
So I'm,
I'm,
I'm conscious of,
of not fucking up something that I think
is really funny.
All right,
so we're going to pack all the comedy
stuff in real quick.
So you're working on like 87 other
things.
You're on Gaffigan,
you're doing something that I just saw a
billboard when other period.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So that's.
I haven't seen it,
but it's like a,
it's like a takeoff.
Downton Abbey.
Is that
abby?
It's as if,
well,
they pitched it to me as the Kardashians
meets Downton Abbey and that's
essentially what it is.
And it's really funny.
Yeah.
All right.
So I,
I knew what channel is it on comedy
central?
I actually know that I should've,
I should've known that.
I apologize.
We have ruined the whole interview.
It doesn't matter to me.
I'm not here to plug shit.
You're not plugging.
I'm here not plugging.
You said.
Well let's talk about the real stuff.
That's all I want to talk about.
All right.
Let's circle back to the real stuff.
Um,
so I mean I've got other shows out to it
doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
I'm on a lot of shows.
What's your favorite thing that you had
up?
All the things you don't see.
So I always associate you with the.
I love the bad stuff,
which probably does that cause you to
roll your eyes Kinda like it was,
you were like,
it was almost as if they,
that whole genre of stuff,
which,
you know,
they did a zillion shows after that best
week ever.
And I in the seventies,
I love the nineties,
I love the twenties or whatever else
they've.
And now every channel has those shows
too.
But you were sort of the one that like.
Got It.
Did you kind of feel like you figured
out what that thing was?
That,
that commentary thing was?
Uh,
I think in a way that some of the other
people who maybe didn't get well when,
when it first started it was much more
sincere.
It was much more like Soleil Frye going,
Oh,
do you remember Wacky Wall crawlers
crawlers.
Right.
And that was never my approach to it.
My approach was just,
just make jokes.
Uh,
I,
I feel totally comfortable shitting on
your childhood right now.
Uh,
and that,
yeah,
they eventually,
the tone of it shifted more towards that
then.
Then the,
can you remember Wacky Wall crawlers?
Tell him?
Yeah.
Speaking of the eighties,
the Sega Genesis,
do anything for you because nothing.
No,
it was after my time.
That was.
So your eight bit Nintendo or colleague?
A Vision or a vision?
A intellivision Atari Twenty 600.
Wow.
So even eight bit Nintendo.
We only have five years apart.
It technology changes,
man moves very fast.
Yeah.
Uh,
I was,
I had graduated from video games and by
the time the Sega Genesis came out.
Yeah.
So I remember once I auditioned for,
I shot a best week ever once and one of
the jokes I did,
it was right when current TV came out
with,
which was Al Gore's television and my
joke was something to this effect that
was like,
Oh,
you know,
Al Gore has a new TV channel called
current TV.
Can you imagine if George W dot Bush
did?
Oh yeah.
Fox News.
Not,
not the most brilliant thing ever,
but I thought I thought pretty solid.
That's a solid joke.
Right?
And I remember the producer kind of
looked at me from the side,
like,
we're not going to be doing that sort of
thing around here.
And I didn't think they aired it,
uh,
my little too political for that.
That was too political for that were
pretty mild,
extremely mild.
But you know,
we live in corporate culture where
everyone's afraid to offend everybody.
How do you deal with that stuff?
So now we can circle back to that.
Like when,
where,
how you ever have you ever said,
I'm sure you know you've gotten into
some heat,
right?
Like I'd said Shit on twitter that gets
people upset.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm not just talking about the Nazis.
I mean like a wider,
wider.
Yeah.
But I mean,
it never really like widespread
condemnation.
It's always coming from the Michelle
Malkin crowd who never called me whiter
than toilet paper once or something like
that.
She said this guy is whiter than old
toilet paper.
Well,
not according to the alt right.
You're not even like my friend.
I know big Ju.
Yeah.
Not even like,
um,
I,
I am not particularly self censorious.
Is that the word?
Yeah.
But do you think about it ever?
Because I do sometimes think,
man,
like there'll be something that I want
to say like really,
and even just I'll be like,
ah,
I gotta change this one word,
not because it's really what I mean is
any different,
but because there's nothing wrong with
that.
There's nothing wrong with making sure
that what you're trying to say is being
heard in the way you want to say it.
Right.
I mean,
when I've gotten in trouble on twitter,
it's generally because I've been too
hasty in terms of how I say something,
not really about what I'm saying.
Um,
I have no problem with there being
consequences for people saying stupid
shit.
The First Amendment allows you to say
whatever you want,
but it doesn't protect you from the
consequences of your speech.
It's just the government can come in so
you can use your speech and then other
people can use their speech to counter
years.
It's actually a beautiful,
beautiful thing.
And I want to be a total asshole on
twitter and say racist.
Horrible Shit.
I can do that.
Yeah.
Um,
but,
you know,
my employer might get upset with me and
I have to be,
I have to understand that going in.
So there's free speech,
but consequences of course there's
always been consequences to free speech.
Uh,
I,
I think the idea,
the concept of free speech is widely
misunderstood in this country.
People think they should be able to sort
of,
uh,
excrete whatever diarrhea they want from
their mouth and they absolutely can.
But if somebody comes along and is like,
I'm going to wash your mouth out with
soap,
got to be prepared to deal with.
Right,
right.
Not Punch you all on what washing your
mouth out,
but they can use their speech,
not going to throw you in jail.
Yeah.
You know,
it's funny,
when I went to Ucla,
as I mentioned before with Milo and I,
we just did one of these,
which we've done many times before and
there were all these protestors and
first they were blocking people from
coming in,
which you can't do that.
You gotta you can protest of course,
but use your,
do a counter rally the next day,
scream all you want,
but you can't throw garbage cans.
And they were getting,
getting in cops faces.
I mean really there were people with
phones,
right in touch with just begging to set
them off,
which goes to the whole other thing we
discussed.
But at one point,
uh,
one of the protestors came in and,
we started screaming in the middle of it
and I stopped and I said,
look,
I bet you that if you ask Milo a
question right now,
a direct question.
So we were going to do this at the q and
a,
but if you ask him something right now,
he'll answer it.
And she just screamed.
I,
Hey,
I.
and I was like,
that's the problem here,
that that's my problem with what's
happening on the left.
It was like,
I opened the door for you to make a
point,
make let's have that exchange of ideas.
But all she could come up with was that.
And it was like,
that was your chance to say,
no,
you are a whatever you want to call him.
You know what I mean?
You're a,
you don't like Muslim people,
you don't like that.
But whenever you want to do like,
this is it,
I'm giving you a chance.
That's a lot of cameras here,
but you're in front of 500 people and
that's what you came up with.
And that's my problem with a lot of
what's going on on the colleges.
It's like,
these people don't even know what
they're protesting.
They're,
they just hear something that they kind
of don't like.
And then they freak out and they want
safe spaces and trigger warnings and all
this other.
Well,
I am,
uh,
as somebody who traffics in free speech
for a living,
I am cognizant of the concern on
campuses that,
that free speech is being shut down.
And of course,
if I,
I,
I oppose that.
I oppose inviting somebody,
the campus and then because some group
has an issue with that person,
just inviting them.
Uh,
uh,
a college campus of all places should be
a place where every point of view is
heard.
Yeah,
no problem with protesting those people,
but as you said,
protest in a respectful way or protest
in a way that is lawful,
right?
You don't have to do it respectfully.
You can be loud and upset and angry and.
Sure.
But,
um,
but I,
I agree with you.
I don't think you can block the,
I mean,
well you can,
I'm just going to get arrested.
That's a,
that's on you.
Um,
but,
but I do think the,
uh,
the,
the college campus thing has gotten,
from what I read,
I mean,
I don't know because I'm not
experiencing it,
but it feels like it's gotten very
intolerant.
Uh,
and that's a problem.
That's a real problem.
And the danger is that these are our
future leaders.
That's what I'm contributing is I don't
think it's a problem.
Ultimately,
I think it's a problem in the sense that
I think it speaks to a larger problem,
but I do think people will leave those
institutions and take their place in
society and it will all be fine.
I'm not,
I'm not concerned about it longterm
particularly really,
I mean you don't think like that.
Just a generation of these people who
had been sort of coddled into the safe
space thing that they're going to be the
20 year olds that are 25 years.
You know what I mean?
That eventually they'll have been so
used to never hearing anything that they
didn't like or,
or everything that they don't like is
hate speech in their eyes that they've
diminished the ability to do this.
That that's my concern.
I think it's a little
what concern.
I've seen no evidence to this point that
it's going to be a problem down the
road.
Maybe it will be.
Maybe it won't be.
I don't know.
I'm not,
I'm not that concerned about it.
Only because I feel like my,
my basic philosophy in parenting and in
life is the kids are all right.
They're going to be fine.
Did you steal that from movie?
I did not.
You were thinking that before?
Yes.
Um,
the kids are all right.
There'll be fine.
It'll all work itself out.
I do think the larger point is this idea
that victimization is empowerment that
you,
by claiming victim status are there by
empowered and thereby take the moral
high ground in whatever you do by the
victim status.
That's problematic to me.
So what do we do about that?
Because that,
that gets to the heart of all of this
thing.
Everyone's trying to figure out how they
are a victim so that they can somehow be
a little more moral problem.
Everyone beneath him is with very few
exceptions.
A lot of people can make a claim,
you know,
their,
their claims are not without merit.
Um,
whether you're black,
Hispanic,
Muslim,
female,
gay,
whatever it is you are,
you can make an argument like you,
you have faced some problems and you
have to deal with them.
Um,
and there's nothing wrong.
I think in asserting and stating your
case and saying,
this is where I feel like society is
coming up short and dealing with us.
But
there's no,
as you're saying,
there's no positive movement beyond
that.
Once you've identified your grievances,
you can't wallow in them
because the world isn't going to give
you anything,
and I don't think the world should give
you anything.
We should all be treated equally.
The playing field has to be equal and
maybe the playing field isn't equal.
Well,
that's I think,
the larger issue that the playing field
isn't equal.
And so
what's so funny about trump is he's
elevated the white male to victim
status.
He's,
he's,
he somehow made white men into victims
and
you know,
that's the final frontier of hilarity.
It's funny to me too because if I make
fun of Hilary,
which I do all the time,
they love it and it gets a zillion
retweets and if I make fun of Bernie,
of course they love it,
but I make fun of anyone and the whole
time they were telling me how much they
love free speech.
And I,
again,
I say this as I understand that free
speech,
Lma you should on there,
but then every time I make a trump on
bullet but joke and now you're saying
you don't get it yet,
and that they can use their free speech
to counter me.
But I always think it's like,
I just want them to understand like a
little bit of the irony here.
You know what I mean?
Like guys,
I'm literally like,
I'm not like,
kill the guy.
I'm like,
right.
It's like,
it's hard
when your guys being attacked and you
know,
in a,
in an election season,
you know,
even as somebody who's not like an and a
hillary supporter,
when I hear her getting attacked,
my hackles go up and I'm like,
and I have to check myself.
I'm like,
why?
Why do you care?
But that's funny because I've had,
I don't really like Hillary and I don't
like trump and I don't know what I may
vote for Gary Johnson.
I'm still in that short.
I'll say something a couple weeks I
guess.
But like,
I've defended Hillary at times because I
think the attacks from a lot of the
Bernie people were totally unfair,
like making it sound like she's truly
this warm on monitoring neo-con.
It's like she's not calling for war
against anyone.
You know what I mean?
I know she's made some bad choices,
but Obama was the president for a lot of
those bad choices too,
like,
you know,
Olivia and whatever else and a lot of
the serious stuff.
But it's like every time I'd defend her
then people say,
Oh,
you're a hillary supporter.
And then I make a joke about trump,
but that isn't it.
Like,
it's like,
it's just,
it's a lot of noise at the end of the
day.
That's,
that's the world you're trafficking in
right now.
The noise world and noise.
Where's the Iot world?
Uh,
come to my house in Connecticut.
You are from Canada.
Great.
Quiet.
Yeah.
No,
but the problem is though,
that you're a heterosexual white man.
And I feel like being around that
privilege wouldn't be that great for me.
For you.
Yeah.
Gay Married Dude.
So technically little better.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what,
we're,
um,
we like,
we like little,
a little,
uh,
diversity up in Connecticut.
What do you,
what do you get a little bit?
Yeah.
You're not in a,
what's the really fat granted.
Sorry.
No,
yeah,
no,
no.
Diversity over there.
I used to,
when I was doing standup,
I would do catering gigs a lot in
Connecticut.
There was not a,
I mean there was the widest thing here
where it's colors of white that I had
never seen before.
That's how white it was.
Yeah.
There's anything wrong with that.
Where I am
is,
is pretty white and it's embarrassing.
It gets to the point where like every
Sunday there's a concerts on the green
in my little town and um,
you know,
the few black families that live in
town,
you know,
you just,
you just stare at them like this.
I know most patronizing way.
Like,
I love you,
I love you.
White guilt is something,
oh,
it's the worst.
It's the worst.
I,
there,
there are,
there are times where I feel like I
could die from white guilt.
Uh,
I was on a cruise ship and the waitstaff
at this dinner,
I dunno,
they're from all over the world and at
one point,
uh,
one,
one of the evenings,
they had to perform a song and dance for
us,
the waitstaff,
and it was unbearable to me.
I,
I honestly felt like if I could die from
white guilt right now because you were
all white patrons,
mostly on the lady's staring at those
people from Bangladesh going,
thank you for coming to dinner tonight.
We hope you like your chicken or
whatever they were saying and you're
just like,
oh my God,
these are the songs about the first
songs are not about the food,
but that would have been.
That would be pretty good.
But the subtext of like,
you are eating this stuff,
we don't eat that well.
They give us is the needs of glad.
We ended this thing on a funny note.
So you see what we did there.
We went serious.
Then we went.
I think there was something funny about
not really,
and it's go.
I thought there was one
moment of humor that phishing email to
introduce me as comedian Michael,
Ian,
but just be with citizen will Ian,
black,
American citizen.
How about depressed dark?
I'm not depressed,
but um,
no,
but I'm trying to make you give you a
little cred,
you know what I mean?
Because if you're depressed or if you
were going to limp or something that way
next time you come out I'll say he's
depressed.
He's limping.
Being he's the first.
He was,
you know,
next time I'll tell them that he
couldn't fly first class.
Yeah.
I did fly first class coming out here on
jet blue on jet blue again.
Are they as good?
Those real nice,
real nice.
It,
it seems like extra.
Like you don't even need all that space.
Oh yeah.
Well you know what it's for.
It's for a halfway through the flight
that come into the jerk you off.
Meanwhile I'm doing it myself back in
coach,
like some kind of schmuck.
And on that note I want to thank Michael
Ian Black.
You can follow him on twitter and if you
want to send them any Nazi names or
anything like that,
he might retweet you or comment on it.
I think that's possible.
Or check out Michael Ian Black Dot com
and the thousand shows that he has in
production at the moment.
Thanks for watching and we'll do it
again next week.